Donald Trump is struggling
in the polls lately
because he has low approval
ratings among many key groups.
Like women, minorities,
young people,
people who wear shoes
when they go to work, and...
and those who want the president
to have a basic grasp
of decency and grammar.
Uh, now,
our research has uncovered
yet another key demographic
that's coming out against Trump.
Who is it?
A) Hoverboard enthusiasts?
B) The cast of the 1993 action
movie Demolition Man?
Very specific group.
-Or C) Cats?
-(laughter)
-Jimmy. -Cats because his hair
looks like he just murdered one.
-HARDWICK: Yes.
-(laughter)
(applause)
For the an...
The answer, of course,
when it's always on this show,
and it's a question of cats,
the answer is always cats.
Uh, let's take a look.
(Trump speaking quietly on TV)
(laughter)
-(growling)
-(laughter)
(hissing)
(applause)
The cat has recognized
the beast!
-(laughter) -This will surely
turn the Internet against Trump,
-'cause cats are so beloved!
-A pussy always knows
-a bigger pussy.
-It does, yes.
Uh, I do think I know something
he could do to get them back.
♪
HARDWICK:
Classic. Classic.
-Okay, I'll vote for him!
-Okay!
-Fine!
-Oh, Keyboard Trump!